we get reviews for everything right one
thing that you know like people have
sort of in my view some Accord context
are like oh biology thinks you should
replace the FDA with the help for drugs
actually there's something called phase
four okay of the FDA which is so-called
post-market surveillance do you know
that that's actually something where in
theory you can go and fill out a form on
the FDA website which basically says
I've had you know a bad experience with
a drug like theirs but for drugs yeah so
it's like it's called medwatch right
um and so you can do like voluntary
reporting and uh you can get like uh you
know like a PDF and and just like upload
it right is this a government uh like is
this the gov yes form 3500b I love it
it's HTML it's gonna be like from the
90s there it's gonna have an interface
yeah designed by somebody who's the
Cobalt slash Fortran programmer right
here we go so here we go so basically
the 3500b I hope to be proven wrong on
that by the way but so 3500b consumer
voluntary reporting when do I use this
form you were heard or had a bad side
effect use a drug which lets unsafe use
syrup the point is FDA already has a
terrible Yelp for drugs yeah it has a
terrible version of it yep what would
the good version look like the fact that
you've never I mean this fact you have
to fill out a PDF to go and submit a
report how do you submit a report at
Yelp or Uber or Airbnb or Amazon you tap
and their star ratings right so just
modernizing FDA 3500b and modernizing
phase four okay
is a huge thing is it can you comment on
that is there what incentive mechanism
forces the the modernization of that
kind of thing here's how it would work
or one possible to create an actual Yelp
yeah here's here's here's here's how
that would work right you go to uh you
know the pharmacy or you know wherever
and you hold up your phone and you scan
the barcode of the drug okay what does
you see instantly you see global reports
right by the way because your biology or
physiology that's Global right
information from Brazil or from Germany
or uh Japan on their physiological
reaction to your the same drug you're
taking is useful to you it's not like a
national boundaries thing so the whole
nation-state model of only collecting
information on by other Americans so
really you want a global kind of thing
just like you know Amazon book reviews
that's like that's a global thing other
things are aggregate at the global level
Okay so
what you want is to see every patient
report and every Doctor around the world
on this drug that might be really
important to your rare or semi-rare
condition just that alone would be a
valuable site who builds that site it's
uh it's it sounds like something created
by capitalism sounds like you could do
it by Capital it would have to be a
company yeah you can definitely do see
these well we don't have a world where a
company is allowed to be in charge of
that kind of thing well I don't know if
Health went out it just seems like a lot
of the
so it depends right basically this is
why you have to pick off individual
elements right there's essentially a
combination of first recognizing that
um DFT is actually bad even be able to
say that that let me put it like this it
does a lot of bad things it is something
which you need to be able to criticize
you might be like well that's obvious
right well in 2010 for example there's a
book that came out if anybody wants to
understand FDA it's called reputation
and power yeah a lot of people don't
want to criticize FDA yeah because they
will retaliate against your biotech or
Pharma company yeah and that retaliation
can be initiated by a single human being
absolutely the best analogy is you think
about the TSA okay have you flown
recently okay do you make any jokes
about the TSA when you're in the TSA
line
uh usually you don't want to but they're
a little more flexible you know what can
I tell a story sure which is
it's similar to this I was uh in Vegas
at a club I don't go to clubs they got
kicked out for the I think the first
time in my life for making a joke with a
balancer
and um because I had a camera with me
and you're not allowed to have a cam
camera and and I said okay cool like
I'll I'll take it out but I made a funny
joke that I don't care to retell but he
was just a little offended he was like
you're you're out I don't care who you
are I don't care who you're with
uh and he proceeded to list me the the
famous people he has kicked off but
there is I mean all of those the reason
I made the joke is I sensed that there
was a an entitlement to this particular
individual like uh where the authority
has gone through my authority yeah right
I almost wanted to poke at that right
and I think the poking The Authority I
quickly learned the lesson well you I
have now been rewarded with the pride I
feel for having poked Authority but now
I'm kicked out of the club that would
have resulted in a fun night with
friends and so on instead I'm standing
alone crying in Vegas which is not a
unique Vegas experience sure actually a
fundamental Vegas experience but that
I'm sure that basic human nature happens
in the FDA as well that's exactly right
so just like with the TSA you know just
to extend the analogy when you're in
line at the TSA right you don't want to
miss your flight that could cost you
hundreds of dollars and so you comply
with apps ludicrous regulations like oh
three ounce bottles well you know you
can take an unlimited number of three
ounce bottles and you can combine them
into a six ounce bottle to the terrorist
technology called mixing yep okay
Advanced right and uh the thing about
this is everybody in line actually some
fairly High you know let's say call it
influence or net worth or whatever
people fly right millions and millions
and millions of people are subject to
these absolutely moronic regulations
it's all but you know I think uh
security theater is is shire's term
right A lot of people know this term so
millions of people are subject to it it
costs Untold billions of dollars in
terms of delays and why not if you just
walk up to right it um it irradiates
people and there's another FDA thing by
the way this is an FDA TSA team up okay
in 2010 the TSA body scanners there were
concerns expressed but when it's a
government to government thing see a.com
is treated with extreme scrutiny by FDA
but it's another.gov well they're not
trying to make a profit so they kind of
sway have them on through okay so these
body scanners were basically like
applied to millions and millions of
people and this huge kind of opt-in
experiment it's almost I think it's
quite likely by the way that
if there was even a slightly increased
cancer risk that the net you know
morbidian mortality from those would
have outweighed the deaths from
terrorism or whatever that were
prevented right you can work out the
numbers but under you can just get the
math under reasonable assumptions it's
probably true
um if it had any increased Mobility
mortality I've not seen the recent
things but I've seen that concern
expressed you know 12 years ago
point being that despite the cost
despite how many people are exposed to
it despite how obviously patently
ludicrous it is you don't make any
trouble nor do people organize protests
or whatever about this because it's
something where
um people the security theater of the
whole thing is is part of it oh well if
we took them away there would be more
terrorism or something like that people
think right but it is fascinating to see
that the populace
puts up with it because it does one of
my favorite things is to listen to
Jordan Peterson who
um I think offline but I think also on
the podcast
you know he's somebody who resists
Authority in every way and even he
goes to TSA with a kind of suppressed
like all the instructions everything
down to when whenever you have like the
yellow thing for your feet they they
force you to adjust it even slightly if
you're off just even I mean it's like uh
it's a cough it's a Kafka novel we're
living like TSA it makes me smile it
brings joy to my heart because I imagine
uh Franz Kafka and I just walking
through there because it's it's it
really is just deeply absurd but and
then the the the whole motivation of the
mechanism becomes distorted by the
individuals involved the initial one was
to reduce the number of terrorist
attacks I suppose right now it's guns
and drugs basically it's like
essentially what they've done is they've
repealed the Fourth Amendment right
search and seizure they can do it
without probable cause everybody is
being searched everybody's a potential
terrorist so they've got probable cause
for everybody in theory and so what they
do they'll post on their website the
guns and drugs or whatever that they see
used in these scanners well of course if
you search everybody you're gonna you're
gonna find some criminals or whatever
but the cost of doing that is dramatic
moreover the fact that people have sure
been trained to have you know compliance
it's like the Soviet Union right where
um you know just grudgingly all right go
along with this extremely stupid thing
what's my point the point is this is a
really stupid regulation that has
existed in plain side of everybody for
20 years we're still taking off our
shoes
okay because some shoe bomb or whatever
number of years ago okay all of this
stuff is there as opposed to there's
resilient other things you could
potentially do different paradigms for
airport security but now apply that to
FDA just like t a lot of what TSA does
is security theater arguably all of it a
lot of what FDA does is safety theater
the difference is there's far fewer
people who go through the aperture
they're the biotech and pharmaceos okay
so you don't have you don't have an
understanding of what it is to deal with
them number one number two is the
penalty is not a few hundred dollars of
missing your flight it is a few million
dollars or tens or hundreds of millions
of dollars for getting your company
subject to the equivalent of a
retaliatory wait time just like that
bouncer threw you out just like the TSA
officer if you make a joke or you know
they can just sit you down and make you
lose your flight right so too can the
FDA just silently
impede the approval of something and
choke you out financially because you
don't have enough Runway to get funded
right so just impose more wait time
guess what we want another six months
you know data is going to take another
six months your company doesn't have the
time you die right if you live you have
to raise around at some dilute
evaluation and now the price gets jacked
up on the other side that's the one
thing that can give by the way in this
whole process
when when you push out timelines from
days to get a vaccine approved with or a
vaccine evaluator rather via challenge
trials to months or years the cost
during that time when you when you it
just increases non-linearly right
because you can't iterate on the product
it all the normal observations if it
takes you 10 years to launch a product
versus 10 days what's the difference in
terms of speed of variation your cost
Etc right so this is part of what it's
not the only thing there's other things
there's AMA and CPT there's other things
but
um this is one of the things that jacks
up prices in the US medical system okay
so now you have something where these
CEOs they're going through this aperture
they are uh they can't tell anybody
about it because if you read reputation
and power okay I'm gonna just quote this
because it's amazing amazing book right
it's written by a guy you know Daniel
Carpenter or a smart guy but he's an FDA
sympathizer he fundamentally thinks it's
like a good thing or what have you
nevertheless I respect Carpenter's
intellectual honesty because he quotes
the CEOs in the book you know verbatim
and you give some paragraphs and
essentially from their descriptions it's
like um think about like a Vietnam War
thing where you've got a pow and they're
like blinking through their eyes I'm
being tortured okay that is the style
when you read Carpenter's book you read
the quotes from these um from these CEOs
oh let me see if I can find it do you
recommend the book it's a good book yeah
or it's it's now a little bit outdated
okay
because it's it's like you know almost
10 years old still as a history of the
FDA
it is well worth reading and by the
reason I say like the FDA is so
insanely important it's so much more
important than many other things that
people talk about but they don't talk
about it right I just want to read his
little blurb for it right this is 2010.
the U.S Food and Drug Administration is
the most powerful regulatory agency in
the world how did the FDA become so
influential and how does it wield its
extraordinary power reputation power
traces the history of FDA regulation
Pharmaceuticals uh revealing how the
agency's organizational reputation as
being the primary source of its power is
also one of its ultimate constraints
Carpenter describes how the FDA
cultivated a reputation for competence
and vigilance throughout the last
century and how this organizational
image has enabled agency to regulate
while resisting efforts to curb its own
authority first of all just that
description alone you're like wait a
second
he is describing this as an active
player it's not like
a DMV kind of thing which is passed
through it's it's talking about
cultivating a reputation it's power
resisting efforts to curb its own
authority right the thing is
now you're kind of Through the Looking
Glass you're like wait a second this is
kind of language I don't usually hear
for regulated Regulatory Agencies the
thing is the kind of person who becomes
the CEO of a giant company what do they
want to do they want to expand that
company
they want to make more profit
similarly the kind of person who comes
to run a regulatory agency or one of the
subunits or that person wants to expand
its Ambit
okay whether is that always obvious and
sorry to interrupt both with the CEO of
the company I know that
the philosophical ideal capitalism is
you want to make the thing more
profitable but
we're also human beings do you think
there's some fundamental aspect to which
we want to do a lot of good in the world
sure but the fiduciary duty will push
people to get the ambitious you know the
profit maximizing expansionist CEO is
selected for
right basically they believe crucially
they're not just this important they're
not just I mean some of them are Grand
Theft Auto make as much money as
possible but they believe in the mission
okay they've come to believe in the
mission and that is a person who's
selected Chomsky actually had this good
thing which is like I believe that you
believe what you believe but if you
didn't believe what you believe you
wouldn't be sitting here right so they
select for the kind of people that are
able to make a lot of money
and in that process uh those people are
able to have construct a narrative that
they're doing good even though what they
were selected for is the fact that they
can make a lot of money yeah and they
may actually be doing good but the thing
is with CEOs we have a zillion images in
television and media movies of the evil
Corporation and the greedy CEO we have
some concept of what CEO failure modes
are like okay now when have you ever
seen an evil regulator
have you can you name a fictional
portrayal of an evil regular can you
name an evil see a lot a lot a lot a lot
but that's so interesting I'm trying I'm
searching for a deeper lesson here
you're right
you're right I mean there is co there is
of portrayals especially in sort of
authoritarian regimes or of the Soviet
Union where there's bureaucracy you know
Chernobyl you can kind of see within
that there's a direct the story of the
regulator but
um
yeah it's it's not as plentiful and it's
also doesn't have often doesn't have a
face to it it's just like bureaucracy is
this amorphous thing that results any
one individual you see they're just
obeying somebody else there's not a face
to it I'll be evil that's right the evil
is the entire machine that's right
that's what I call the school of fish
strategy by the way it's something where
you are an individual and you can be
signaled out but there's more
accountability for one person's bad
tweets than all the wars in the Middle
East right because it's a school of fish
yeah right so if the establishment is
wrong if the bureaucracy is wrong
they're all wrong at the same time who
could have known whereas if you deviate
then you are a deviation who can be
hammered down okay now the school fish
strategy is unfortunately very
successful because uh you know truth is
whatever if you just always ride with
the school of fish and turn when they
turn and so on unless there's a bigger
school of fish that comes in you
basically can never be proven wrong all
right and this is actually you know of
course someone who believes in truth and
believes in you know Innovation and so
on just physiologically can't ride with
the school of fish you just have to say
what is true or do what is true right
still you've described correctly you
know how it's faceless right so I will
give two examples of fictional
portrayals of evil regulators
one is actually the original
Ghostbusters
okay I did not expect that one but yes
yeah so the EPA is actually the villain
in that where they flip a switch that
lets out all the ghosts in the city and
essentially the guys coming in with a
head of steam as this evil regulator
that just totally arrogant doesn't
actually understand the private sector
or or the consequences of their actions
and they force the and crucially they
bring a cop with them with a gun so it
shows that a regulator is not simply you
know some piece of paper but it is the
police right and that cop with the gun
forces the Ghostbusters to like release
the game and the whole thing spreads
yeah the second example is Dallas Buyers
Club which is more recent and that
actually shows the FDA blocking a guy
who with a life-threatening illness uh
you know with AIDS from getting the
drugs to trees condition and from
getting into other people right
those are just two portrayals but in
general what you find is when you talk
about FDA with people
one thing I'll often hear from folks is
like why would they do that
right they have no mental model of this
they kind of think of it as
why would the why would this uh thing
which you think of as sort of the DMV
they don't think the DMV as like this
active thing okay why would the FDA do
that well if it is because it's filled
with some ambitious people that want to
keep increasing the power of the agency
just like the CEO wants to increase the
profit of the company right I use that
word Ambit right why Ambit because these
folks are we know the term greedy right
these folks are power hungry
they want to have the maximum scope and
sometimes Regulatory Agencies collide
with each other right even though FDA is
under HHS sometimes it collides with HHS
and they've got regulations at conflict
um you know for example HHS says
everybody's supposed to be able to have
access to their own medical record FDA
didn't want people to have access to
their own personal genomes that
conflicts okay
um and both of those are kind of
anti-corporate statutes that were put
out but HHS this thing being targeted at
the hospitals and FDA being targeted
with the personal genomics companies but
those conflicted right
um it's a little bit like cftc and SEC
have a door jam over who will regulate
cryptocurrency right sometimes
Regulators fight each other
but they fight each other there they
fight companies they are they're active
players this reputation in power book
The reason I mention it is
um I want to see if I can find this
quote so let me see if I can find this
quote reputation and power
organizational image and pharmaceutical
regulation at the FDA
so
genentech's executive G Kirk Robb right
Rob would describe regulatory approval
for his products as a fundamental
challenge facing his company and he
would depict the administration a
particularly Vivid metaphor I've told
the story hundreds of times to help
people understand the FDA when I was in
Brazil I worked on the Amazon River for
many months selling terramycin for
Pfizer I hadn't seen my family for eight
or nine months they're flying into Sao
Paulo and I was flying down from some
little village on the Amazon to Manus
and then to Sao Paulo I was a young guy
in his 20s I couldn't wait to see the
kids one of them was a year old baby the
other was three I miss my wife
there's a quonset hut in front of just a
little dirt strip with a single engine
plane to fly me to menus I roll up and
there's a Brazilian Soldier there
the military Revolution happened
literally the week before so this
Soldier is standing there with his
machine gun and he said to me you can't
come in
I speak in pretty good Portuguese by the
time I said my God my plane my family I
gotta come in he said again you can't
come in I said I gotta come in and he
took his machine gun took the safety off
and pointed at me and said you can't
come in and I said oh now I got it I
can't go in there and that's the way I
always describe the FDA the FDA is
standing there with a machine gun
against a pharmaceutical industry so you
better be their friend rather than their
enemy they're the boss if you're a
pharmaceutical firm they own you body
and soul
okay that's the CEO of a successful
company Genentech he say he's told the
story hundreds of times
and Regulatory approval is a fundamental
challenge facing this company because
if you are regulated by FDA they are
your primary customer if they cut the
cord on you you have no other customers
and in fact until very recently with the
Advent of social media no one would even
tell your story it was assumed that you
were some sort of
you know corporate criminal that they
were protecting the public from that
you're going to put poison and milk you
know like the melamine scandal in China
I'm not saying those things don't exist
by the way they do exist that's why
people are like they can immediately sum
into mind all the examples of corporate
criminals right that's why I mentioned
those fictional stories those templates
even if Star Wars doesn't exist how many
times have you heard a Star Wars
metaphor or whatever for something right
Breaking Bad you know go ahead yeah but
the pharmaceutical companies are stuck
between rock and a hard place because
the reputation if they go to Twitter
they go to social media they have
horrible reputation so it's like they
don't yes but why is that because
reputation and power FDA beat down the
reputation of Pharma companies just like
EPA helped beat down the reputation of
oil companies and as it says over here
right in practice dealing with the fact
of FDA power meant a fundamental change
in corporate structure and culture at
Abbott and at Genentech Rob's most
Central transformation was in creating a
culture of acquiescence towards a
government agency as was done at other
drug companies in the late 20th century
Rob essentially fired officials at
Abbott who were insufficiently compliant
with the FDA what that means is de facto
nationalization of the industry
via regulation
just to hover on that that's a really
big deal
because if their primary customer is
this government agency
then it has nationalized it just
indirectly right this is partially
what's just happened with
um Microsoft Apple Google Amazon the
other Maga okay they have been yeah
that's funny well done
yeah I didn't even think about that as
well done it was right so it's a so the
you know like I have this trees like
Mega Republicans and mega Democrats
right okay
oh damn it so many things you've said
today will just get stuck in my head uh
they changed the way you think catchy
something about a catchy phrasing of
ideas is makes me even more powerful uh
so yeah okay so that's happening in the
text it's happening in Tech so Facebook
is the outlier because Zuck still
controls a company but just like I mean
why had Tech had a good reputation for a
while because there wasn't a regulatory
agency whose justification was
regulating these corporate criminals
right once that is the case the
regulatory agency basically comes back
to Congress each year and if you look at
its budget approvals it's saying we find
this many guys we found this many
violations right they have an incentive
to exaggerate the threat in the same way
that a prosecutor or you know policeman
has a quota right like these are the
police you know one way I describe it
also is like
um you know like a step down
Transformers you have high voltage
electricity it's generated at the power
plant and it comes over the wires and
then there's step down Transformers that
turn it into a lower voltage that you
can just deal with out of your
appliances right similarly you have
something where the high voltage of like
the US military or the police and that
is transmuted down into a little letter
that comes in your mailbox saying pay
your 50 parking ticket
where it's a piece of paper so you don't
see the gun attached to it but if you
were to defy that it's like Grand Theft
Auto where you get one star two star
three stars four stars five stars and
eventually you know you have some some
serious stuff on your hands okay so once
you understand that you know every law
is backed by force like that Brazilian
guy with the machine gun that uh Rob
mentioned these guys are the regulatory
police okay now
see for a time what happened was
you had the captured industry because
all of the folks who were in
Pharmaceuticals were as Carpenter said
um
the culture of acquiescence towards the
FDA the FDA was their primary customer
so just like in a sense it's rational
you know Amazon talks about being
customer obsessed right what Rob did was
rational for that time right what geek
Rob did was uh saying our customers the
FDA that's our primary customer nobody
else matters they are satisfied first
every single trade-off that has to be
made is FDA right and uh you know really
that's why the two most important
departments that many pharmaceutical
companies argue all are Regulatory
Affairs and IP not r d right because one
is artificial scarcity of Regulation
which jacks up the price and the other
is artificial scarcity the patent which
allows people to maintain the high price
right so this entire thing is just like
you know college education these things
may at some point of being a good
concept but the price has just risen and
risen risen until it's at the limit
price and Beyond Okay so
what has changed what's changed is in
the 2010s uh the late 2000s and 2010s
and so on with the Advent of social
media with the Advent of a bunch of
millionaires
um like who are independent uh with the
Advent of
um Uber and Airbnb right with the Advent
of cryptocurrency with the domination of
trust and institutions it used to be
really taboo to even talk about the
fda's potentially bad in like you know
2010 2009 okay but now people have just
seen face plant after face plant by the
institutions and people are much more
open to the concept that they may
actually not have it all together and I
think it's a you know you you probably
see some tracking pull or something like
that I wouldn't be surprised if it's
like a 20 or 30 point drop after the CDC
failed to control disease in the FDA
failed and the entire biomedical
regulatory establishment and scientific
establishment was saying masks don't
work before they do this was just a
train crash of all the things that
you're paying for that you you
supposedly think are good as I mentioned
one response is to go Q Anon and people
say oh don't trust anything but the
better response is decentralizing FDA
Okay so
I will say one other thing which is I
mentioned um you know this concept of
improving the form 3500b where you like
scan go ahead yeah yeah right that just
makes me laugh that I could just tell
the form sucks by the fact that it has
that code name sorry yeah yeah yeah yeah
exactly right ux is broken at every
layer yeah so so they have a bad Yelp
for drugs could we make a better one we
could make a better one just modern ux